at carnegie mellon university innovation
is part of our DNA we are defined by our
creative spark tireless work ethic and
commitment to problem-solving we bring
multi-talented dream teams together like
no one else can we set the standard for
engineering education we helped
establish the field of artificial
intelligence we created the first
internet search engine we continue to
revolutionize business education and
train generations of artists composers
and actors at Carnegie Mellon students
are deeply involved in research we push
the envelope with new educational models
that anticipate emerging professions and
the changing world mentored by our
premier faculty students can explore and
combine disciplines in new ways we
produce students who think creatively
who are well grounded in their field and
more apt to leave they are architects of
change at every stage of our evolution
our innovations have been made possible
by philanthropy that prizes guts in
audacity that's why we're asking you to
join inspire innovation the campaign for
Carnegie Mellon University now is a
critical time for this campaign it is
something we all can work to achieve
that is something that will add a
tremendous amount to our endowment when
you think about what can I go do to help
the world position itself for the future
there's probably no better place to put
your time energy and ultimately money
than into universities because these are
the places that are educating students
that are doing the research they're
really shaped the world
by investing in the university today you
have an opportunity to accelerate that
you have an opportunity to take this and
put it on an even greater exponential
ramp for success and impact a major goal
of inspire innovation is to build our
endowment you can help us do this by
supporting any of the universities
priority areas your support through
scholarships fellowships and other
student life initiatives will enable us
to educate the best and the brightest
students you can help us retain
world-class faculty by supporting
endowed professorships and funds for
faculty startup and research by
investing in Annual Giving programs
unrestricted funds and support for our
libraries you can help us sustain
breakthrough innovations finally
additional funding for new and renovated
facilities will renew the campus support
research and enhance student life the
world is full of problems and Carnegie
Mellon is the ultimate innovative
problem-solving University we thrive on
that the harder the problem the more
important the problem the better
Carnegie Mellon responds
we make a relevant impact on the lives
of everyday people a world leader and
technology and robotics we are creating
smarter homes for families homes that
can alert us to dangers and better serve
us as we age we develop new health tools
to diagnose diseases like cancer
personalized treatments and predict the
side effects of medications before
billions of dollars are spent
we are unlocking the secrets of the
human mind to discover new therapies for
disorders like autism we invent
solutions across disability this is the
place where engineers computer
scientists policy makers economists and
designers work together for a more
sustainable world we are a leader in
areas like green chemistry and
sustainable design Carnegie Mellon is
developing new technologies to make
solar and other alternative energies
practical and more affordable we're
discovering new ways to make our air and
water cleaner and make burning fossil
fuels less harmful to our planet we
don't just imagine the future we create
from the start our strengths and
research and the arts have grown
together yielding innovations that
affect everything from how we
communicate to the design of the places
where we live and work by combining our
strengths in the arts with technology we
are creating the art forms of the future
like art that is aware of you
we get out of the ivory tower and into
the world Carnegie Mellon has always
responded to the needs of the real world
where economic challenges are global
international banks and financial
organizations seek the counsel of our
monetary policy experts we prepare
future engineers to manage innovation in
multinational environments Carnegie
Mellon is a world leader in social and
decision sciences exploring how
psychological and economic factors shape
decision making we capitalize on the
synergies between information systems
and public policy and deal with new
challenges like credit card debt in
global cyber threats
we fearlessly reinvent our areas of
excellence we will be at the forefront
of next generation computing and the
communication technologies that will
drive our interconnected world each day
Internet users come into contact with
ideas that originated at Carnegie Mellon
we build on our existing technology
expertise to move into new areas
revolutionising education seeking to
understand the origins of the universe
and transforming science itself
at carnegie-mellon we imagine the
impossible
we are entrepreneurial educators virtual
storytellers eco visionaries
computational biologists interactive
artists and behavioral economists we are
architects of change we invite you to
support our new ideas and help create a
better future together we can inspire
innovation